In this video, we'll talk about placement and model editing using some of the newer
tools for Unreal.
So let's get started.
The topics we'll look at first is placement and adjusting pivots, and model editing will
come next when we look at some of the sculpting tools that Unreal has to offer.
The first thing we'll need to do is turn on these new tools in our plugins in Unreal.
So let's go and do that real quick.
So in Unreal, we're going to go to our settings, plugins, and you can also go there through
edit plugins.
And as we call this up, we're going to go and type in model.
You can type in mesh too if you want to.
Oh, kind of make sure I type it correctly.
You can also type in mesh and turn on anything that you need with mesh editing.
But in this case, we just need the modeling tools for editor mode.
This will give us our ability to be able to edit interactively and make our models and
shapes the way that we need on the fly.
And that's pretty convenient to be able to do so.
But there are some aspects of this tool that are still evolving and getting better and
stronger.
We'll go ahead and close that out.
Now when you do turn it on, Unreal will ask you to reboot.
So just keep that in mind.
So as it reboots, you're going to now have the option to have modeling.
Be able to activate that.
You want to hit Shift 6 if you want to use those hotkeys.
Now one of the first things I want to mention, which is super important to consider, is if
you are going to change maybe you want to change the pivot on an existing instanced
object, it's best to be able to make a copy of that first and then drag it in and work
with that instanced object.
So if you are changing any pivots or even sculpting, you want to be able to make sure
and understand that Unreal's instancing feature is going to change things all across the board.
So right now if I changed the pivot on this object here and I hit apply, it would affect
everything in there that's already been duplicated in the scene and related to it.
So what you want to do is go to your object's original area, original source, and I right
click and I can duplicate this object and then now I can bring this object in the scene.
And then now if I want to change its pivot, we know that it's only going to affect this
new duplicate and not everything else.
So just keep that in mind.
In older versions of Unreal with this tool, it may not have been as much of a problem,
but here you do want to keep in mind the instancing that occurs.
So if I did sculpt on this object and he was duplicated in the world, it would actually
show up on all the different assets.
So keeping a copy can be helpful specifically if you want things to be unique.
But I sculpted mine in such a way that even rotating these, they look like a brand new
spike.
So you can also do that too.
It's kind of tricky.
It's kind of like doing things like with a tree, you rotate it, it looks like a brand
new tree.
It's just the way you made it.
You made it asymmetrical.
So those are things to consider.
So now we have this object here and say we want to change its pivot.
Now there is the old way to change pivots where you would simply just go in here and
there's multiple ways to get this done.
But what I normally do is go to pivot and I'll say, hey man, I'm going to reset my pivot
offset and then I would change my pivot to what I want.
And then I would say, set my pivot offset.
Those were the two steps that I would do.
But you can also just say, hey, move if you need it to temporarily be at a particular
spot.
So I can say, set my pivot offset here temporarily, move your piece of geometry or rotate it for
that particular aspect of whatever you're doing.
And then you can just click away and go back and it will go back to its default.
So that could be helpful in some instances.
But our new tool works pretty well.
In the fact that you can go in here and you can go to our transform, I can edit the pivot,
move the pivot physically as you would in a regular designated 3D application.
I can move this here or I can choose center, bottom, top, left, right, back and front.
All of these things can be quickly, can quickly give you access to those position aids.
And then you would hit apply, which is super helpful.
But remember, if he's duplicated in the world and maybe there's another copy of him that's
truncated and is rotated that is tweaked in some way and you change that pivot, it will
affect that duplicate in this current version of Unreal.
So let's keep those things in mind.
Another tool that we have to is if we want to sculpt this item.
Now we can cut into it, we can offset it, we can even displace it and we can even warp
it.
So if I wanted to go in here and do some warping, that's available too.
So you got to be careful though.
Anything if you go beyond a particular amount, you can stretch your UVs beyond their limit.
So let's keep that in mind.
But we're going to mainly focus on the two sculpting tools here.
So I'm going to go to the generic sculpt initially and I'm going to click on this one and I'm
going to zoom in on my scene.
Let me hit the control button so you can see exactly where my mouse is at.
So I can start sculpting on this object in such a way and it does it pretty cleanly using
the default sculpt.
Now again, everything has its limit.
So if you go beyond the UV space or the shape, you may get some push and pull on your texture
and you may at times even get holes in the geometry.
So you might want to smooth these out and hitting the shift key allows you to do a little
bit more of the smoothing.
You can see there are a few options here and the ones we'll mainly focus on is in the sculpting
area and also brush size and fall off.
And our fall off is at one, which actually works pretty well.
But you can also adjust that according to what you need.
There's even a freeze a target area if you need and we're not going to get into that
just here.
But you can also control how this smoothing is going to occur with your fall off.
And in our sculpt, you can see we have definitely a lot of different choices to choose from.
Now again, we're using the default normal sculpt and it works pretty well with the UVs.
But where you can really run into some problems and you got to be careful is when you decide
to do, let me hit accept on this, when you decide to do a Dinosculpt.
Now the Dinosculpt is awesome.
The fact that it's really tries to imitate what you get from like 3D code and ZBrush
where you get a little bit more dynamic, a little bit more organic with your sculpting.
But in that case, it also can be at the cost of your UVs where you can get some stretching
in your texture.
So when you do play with this, just keep that in mind that you may have to go back in there
tweak your UVs.
Now we do have some UV tools and they're great, but they are also coming in a little hot.
They're evolving.
So when you experiment with these and work with them, just make sure you save as you
go as well as make sure that you understand the concepts of working with it.
Now we're not going to get into in this particular case, we're mainly going to be working at
looking at shape and positioning for this particular course.
All right.
So as I go in here and I edit these, you'll see the Dinosculpt come into play.
You can see here, this is was a normal sculpt, but over here I can do Dinosculpting.
We can kind of push things a little bit.
I'll do a little bit of smoothing again, hitting the shift key, do some smoothing and that
can help any weirdness with your UVs, your textures being hit.
And then we can hit accept.
And we can see it did a pretty good job.
There's a little bit of weirdness right here where we're pushing the shapes beyond the
polygon limit.
And in that case, we can go in here and maybe do a little bit more of a shift and smoothing
aspects and fix some of those issues that may occur.
It still gets a little bit of the stretching there.
And that's something you do need to be aware of because we really sculpted it pretty hard
on that one.
The generic sculpt versus the Dinosculpt is where you're going to see a lot of that type
of effect happening, where you're going to get some really weird, obscure effects in
here when it comes to warping and distorting things.
Escape for a second, we'll go back to Dinosculpt and we'll then again, you can do some smoothing.
We can go up a little bit here in this case, pushing things back a little bit more to normal.
And you may still see a bit of warping because this shape isn't the regular shape of this
object.
And I used a bit of moving in some cases.
Some of the stuff had already been there.
So we can use the move tool, move some of this back in based on the range of my brush.
And hit accept.
So it's a little bit less, but they're still getting a little bit of warping here because
we created space that didn't exist before.
So just keep those things in mind when you're doing that.